In 1947,
Armstrong bought a tape recorder.
Commercial tape recorders were new at
this point.
He was one of the first people in
America to buy one like everyone else,
if his generation who first got his
hands on a tape recorder,
he would play with it.
He bought it to tape his shows,
his live shows so that he could study
them.
But he started taping conversations,
uh,
with,
with friends,
backstage conversations.
And he also taped off all of his record
library from his home so he could travel
with it because Armstrong was on the
road 300 nights a year.
And he missed his records.
He loved to listen to music.
He kept the tapes because he was a very
self aware person,
you know,
he wrote two autobiographies of his own
and he thought deeply about the meaning
of his own experience.
So he realized fairly early on that he
was creating a kind of personal archive
of,
of information through these types.
By the time of his death in 1971,
there were about 650 reels of tape.
They were kept after his death in a non
climate controlled attic at his house in
Queens.
And so although everybody who knew him
knew about the existence of the tapes,
it was generally assumed that they
wouldn't be playable by the time anybody
got their hands on them.
Um,
but it wasn't true.
Uh,
when the contents of the house became
part of the Armstrong Archive,
the archivists did digital transfers of
all the tapes and they were all playable
and they're all in,
in,
depending on the circumstances under
which they were recorded.
Very good sound.
I was the first person to write a book
about Armstrong,
who,
who came along after these types became
available to researchers.
And it was really an extraordinary
experience at Armstrong was a very
unselfconscious man.
So if there was ever a point at which he
was aware of the microphone,
so to speak,
it went away early.
So when you listen to these tapes,
you are stepping into a time machine.
You are eavesdropping on the private
life of a great important and
unselfconscious men.
Sometimes he's putting on a little show.
He does a little mock radio shows,
uh,
there are tapes where he plays along
with old records of his tapes where he
plays records for ms dot collection and
talks about them and they're fascinating
too,
but the most important tapes are the
candidate tapes where he simply,
he simply started the tape recorder
during a dinner party or in his dressing
room or in the bedroom at a hotel room
after the show and just let it run and
whatever he wants to talk about.
Whatever the people who are with him are
talking about is what gets taken down on
recorder.
So
I was fascinated by the idea that these
tapes might show us in Armstrong that we
didn't know.
In one sense they don't because
Armstrong was an unselfconscious person
and when he got onstage,
as everybody I spoke to who knew him,
told me what you saw was what you got.
He was what he seemed to be.
But in private he was more candid.
I think much more sharp.
I don't mean sharp is an intelligent.
I mean sharp is in,
in testy,
difficult sometimes because he had a
temporary.
That was something that he didn't show
it in public.
He held grudges and he talks about some
of those grudges and the tapes,
grudges against musicians he'd worked
with that he thought had double crossed
him,
a managers or people who booked him that
had mistreated him.
He talks very candidly about the
difficulties he had with the gangsters
of Chicago in 1930,
31 back when he was really having
serious run ins with him.
Uh,
he talks about his marijuana arrest in
1930 in California,
not a subject that you would go around
and give interviews about 1960 in the
United States.
You hear him getting high with friends.
Uh,
you hear him in one amazing tape trying
to get his wife into bed.
You hear him talking to girlfriends when
his wife wasn't around.
You hear him talking about racism.
You hear him talking about people he had
logged in,
music that he had loved and whatever
inhibition he felt in public about
talking about certain matters is gone in
these types.
Uh,
and it,
did.
They bring you closer to him than
anything possibly could closer even than
talking to people who knew him and I
talked to quite a few of those people.
It's not quite right to say that they
didn't emerge in,
in one famous episode,
he blew up in front of a reporter when
Dwight Eisenhower,
who was then president,
was hesitating about sending the
national guard and to desegregate the
schools of little rock.
He was extremely candid on that
occasion,
but by that time,
Armstrong was perceived as being an
accommodationist on racial matters by
younger blacks because Armstrong had the
manners of an earlier generation.
He was an entertainer.
He didn't perform in public with any
kind of confrontational edge.
Uh,
there were those who called him an uncle
Tom because he had,
you know,
some of the comic mannerisms of,
of somebody who had grown up with
minstrel shows,
which is perfectly natural for a man who
was born in New Orleans in 1901.
But in the late fifties,
he was widely perceived as being soft on
these matters.
Since it's not soft,
all of them.
When you listen to the tapes,
you realize that although he is himself
devoid of any kind of racist sentiment,
there's no reverse racism and Armstrong
at all.
Uh,
he is absolutely frank about things that
have happened to him about the anger
that he feels about episodes where he
felt that he'd been mistreated,
especially in Hollywood,
uh,
where he was sometimes treated as
something of a servant on the movies
that he made.
And he speaks about them with,
with great candor and great anger.
And if you already viewed Armstrong with
a proper historical perspective,
you're not going to be shocked by this.
But for people who,
who have this notion that Armstrong with
some kind of uncle Tom Listening to the
tapes as an Iro.